hi uh my name is Vivek I work in the
research team so my talk today is going
to be about can you tune my car this is
a question that I get at least once a
week on discard uh
so we have a discard uh I'm sure how
many of you have been on our Discord
okay and we have a development tuning
Channel how many of you have been on the
tuning Channel
okay great so if you go to the tuning
Channel you see a lot about good tuning
bad tuning and ugly maybe not ugly just
good and bad so if you're new to open
pilot or new to Discord or new to the
channel you might be wondering what
exactly needs tuning right so everything
that we spoke about today we never
really spoke anything about like you
know tuning something so what exactly
needs tuning and for that you have to
understand how is your car different
when it comes to open pilot like how are
cars different with respect to open
pilot
so so these are some of the brands that
we uh that we support so some ways in
which cars are different are you know
the wheelbase is different and the
wheelbase is the distance between the
front and the rear wheel so as you can
imagine different cars to have different
sizes so the wheelbase is different they
also have different widths and as a
consequence they also have different
masses like some cars the lights some
cars are heavy we have we rent we
support from like tiny cars too like the
RAM and they're quite different in that
way
cars are also different when it comes to
other things like steering ratio
steering ratio is
how much your car turns with how much
steering wheel turned and that is
different in each platform and also
different across brands
your tire stiffness which is like again
like the quality of your tire how much
like torque your tire provides while
turning stuff like that is also
different
the center of gravity is different in
all cars depends on how many people are
in the car and stuff like that and then
actuator lags so each brand and each
platform have different ways of
processing the signal that we send to
the car so when we say okay you know do
this manure or do this turn there is
like some internal processing happening
in the car and then it actually actuates
that in the final actuator and there is
like a lag which is also different for
different brands so all of these things
are different
so to understand how like these
differences in cars manifest let's look
at this example so these are three cars
the Honda Fit the Toyota Corolla and the
ram all of them are like you know quite
different as you can see the images
so let's focus on lateral movement right
so let's assume all cars are moving at
20 meter per second uh all all of them
have a 10 degree steering angle and
they're all traveling on a flat Road
so this is the trajectory that these
cars would take so this is the uh
the UI versus X so if you start at the
same position this is what the cars
would do Under the same instructions so
it's I guess right now it's clear that
we need to really understand like you
know what exactly happens when you give
instructions to cars
so how do we actually learn these things
we learn these things using something
called the vehicle model so to
understand the vehicle model let's look
at some high school physics so you're
turning uh you're in a car and you're
about to go to a turn uh so this is the
front view so let's assume that the road
is banked uh and let's also assume there
is some wind because why not uh in this
so this is the top view of your car so
your four wheels and your front wheels
are turning so in uh I don't know how
many of you are familiar with car
Dynamics so this is something that we
call a slip angle the angle between your
direction of motion to your heading is
called the slip angle and that
determines a lot of the Dynamics of your
car so you can see that there are forces
that act on the tires so this is
basically something called a bicycle
model which is you assume that your car
is a bicycle which is not a good
assumption but it really works it's like
a it's a simplified Assumption of your
car and then you know this is where this
center of gravity is and then you have
like you have if you draw the free body
diagram and the forces that act on this
on this object you end up with something
like this so let's quickly go through
this uh it looks quite scary but it's
not so what we have is the desired
curvature that you know we get from the
model and from the planner we know we
the car has to do something right at
some curvature at some speed so we have
the yorit if we make some very generous
assumptions about cars and about our
Dynamics we can find out from the state
space equation we can find what the slip
angle is to achieve this particular unit
and when we know the slip angle we can
find the steering angle required to that
you're required to like turn to achieve
uh like the maneuver that you want to do
so this is some this is called the
vehicle model so we have a Daemon in uh
open parallel called param C which
learns this all these parameters inside
that we that I spoke about and then it
learns like the Dynamics of your
particular car
so it learns things like the steer ratio
the tire stiffness the road roll the
steering angle offsets and all of these
things and it learns all of these things
uh about your car with your particular
car so another interesting thing is that
the steering angle offsets is basically
to go straight you would assume you
should keep your steering angle at zero
degree but that's not true all cars have
some Offset you have to keep your
steering angle at like two degrees or
minus two degrees or whatever and that
depends on your car and how long you've
driven it and stuff like that so this is
also something that we learn uh live
while you're driving
a fun fact is that as a consequence of
learning all this we also know when
you're when you have a bad wheel
alignment which is if your wheels are
aligned badly and then you know if you
want to go straight you have to hold
your wheel at like a 10 degree angle or
something like that a lot of people you
know come on discard and they're like
hey I just installed open pilot it
drives fine but it like you know it
tries to when I hold it when the wheel
is straight it tries to go right and
when it's going straight the wheel is
slightly to the right it's my device
broken and then we tell them what the
problem is and then they come back a few
days later saying hey about that I went
to a mechanic and you know he said my
wheel alignments were wrong and then
they fixed it and now my car drives
perfectly so this is something that from
your logs and from the tolerances that
we know we can tell you if yeah your car
has a bad wheel alignment okay so now we
learned all of this stuff so where do we
actually use it
so you know as you can know as you see
uh we have sensors which is called
agnostic we have models and planning
which is also pretty much car agnostic
uh but the actuators are specific to
cars so this is where uh you know we
convert the car agnostic stuff to the
car specific stuff
so
so we started with uh a maneuver that we
wanted to do which is like a steering
angle so to achieve the same thing so we
used a traditional PID control so we
have a steering angle and the car gives
us back the steering angle so we're like
okay go 10 degrees and we have a classic
PID control to make sure that the car is
driving 10 degrees and then everything
is good
uh so this is the distribution of the uh
lateral acceleration error when uh when
you're doing these Maneuvers so it's
very important for us to understand how
well the car is performing the Maneuvers
that you are asking it to do and for
that we have a whole bunch of metrics
but one of the most important is
absolute lateral acceleration error so
what do we mean by this we mean that so
when the instruction is to perform some
manure with some lateral acceleration
and the car is doing something else so
what's the difference between these two
and we have to drive this number down so
as you can see the straight is the
distribution is like the the average is
much lower than interns which means that
while going straight you're pretty much
you know it's together free but in turns
it's like it's it's slightly worse so
this is a metric just remember this
metric we'll keep coming back to this
again and again so we had all of this
right but then we realized that in our
Fleet
the way we actually give instructions to
cars we don't actually give the steering
angle for like overwhelmingly most of
our cars we give the torque we give the
steering torque that you have to apply
to the car so realize wait a minute we
were going about this whole roundabout
way of we have the curvature we do all
of these equations and we find the
steering angle and then we close the
loop on the steering angle and then
finally send torque so you know we can
just like circumvent that and then try
to find torque so this was a whole
effort called torque control which we
released in 0815
so let's leave us at the same maneuver
that we did earlier which is this car
doing this turn at this angle now if you
focus on the tire patch that is on in
contact with the road uh so this is like
the free body diagram of this tire patch
so you can see that these are the forces
that develop on your tire during a turn
so you can see the wheel is heading is
this the wheel is moving here so this is
the slip angle
so what this effectively says is that
the wheel torque is you have a resultant
force that is like X behind the center
of the wheel so basically the wheel
torque is this resultant Force F times
uh this pneumatic Trail and for a
particular configuration of your car and
your vehicle this is constant so the key
Insight here was that the wheel torque
is proportional to the lateral
acceleration that you want to achieve
adjusting for gravity and from data the
second Insight was that the wheel torque
is directly proportional to the steering
torque that you apply when you account
for some friction and friction is you
know when you when you're turning right
and immediately if you want to turn left
there is like a bit of friction in your
steering column that you have to account
for so basically uh
you know we can get the wheel uh we can
if so we have a lateral acceleration
that we want to achieve and we all we
need to do is learn one proportionality
factor to directly you know to know what
command to send to the car this is great
news
so we can find one value which for each
platform and everything is good we
implemented this uh so you can see this
is the lateral acceleration that is
desired and this is the steering command
that we sent to the car to achieve this
and this is for a Toyota RAV4 and this
looks pretty linear to me uh so this is
what we implemented
in
0815 and torque control and then this is
the result so again the same metric
absolute lateral acceleration error uh
for some car stereo Prius and you can
see that the torque control was much
better than the simple PID tune for uh
this PID on directly the steering angle
so this is great news and this is even
great because the subtlety is that these
higher errors lead to other things that
are undesirable like they lead to more
ping-ponging they lead to like wandering
in the lay and they lead to other things
like that which we don't want so this is
great news and you know everything looks
looks good here
but then okay let's revisit the
assumptions that we made the Assumption
was the pneumatic Trail was like
constant for a given vertical load which
means for a given configuration of your
car but then you know like even among
platforms even among like Toyota Priuses
like each startup price is pretty
slightly different depending on like how
how long you've used it what you put in
a car and stuff like that
uh the contact tire patch is also quite
different it depends on your quality of
your wheels it depends on how much air
you have in your wheels it depends on
which road conditions you're driving on
uh and the steering column friction
depends on you know your wear and tear
of your car and and
Etc so
this is also uh corroborated by the fact
that when we do the same calculation to
find the the single factor for each
platform on every car of that platform
we see that there is like a big
difference in the big distribution in
the value that is learned so these are
each partic this is the distribution of
the factor that I spoke about uh and you
can see that for a even one platform
there is a wide range of values so we
set the value somewhere here in between
and then it's great for people whose
cars are like here but then if people's
cars are like here or here I mean it's
not that great so this is this was like
the motivation for us to go down this
route of you know we don't we're not
happy with platform averages we want
something tuned for your specific car
the car that you drive
so this inspired uh this effort called
Talk D which is auto-tune uh so
basically what it does is
the same thing that we were doing
offline on like all the data from April
like a particular platform like the RAV4
now we do the same computation on your
device while you're driving so when you
start driving we collect data and then
once it meets uh certain
conditions we fit the we use the
algorithm what that we were doing
offline in your car and then now we have
one constant that is learned on your car
and the great thing about it is that if
you change your tires next week or if
you refill air or whatever if like you
have uh you put some stuff on top of
your car to go somewhere like it learns
live and it adapts live and then you
know your your performance becomes
better as a result of that which is
great
so going back to the same metric so this
is for Toyota Highlanders you can see
that the torque control was red which
was already an improvement over the
previous generation stuff but talk B was
an even better improvement over that
which is great this make this means that
if your platform has like a bunch of
versions where you know like the
versions are different but they all
they're somehow called it the same
platform it's still fine because we
don't care about that and we learn it
for your particular car
so let's we visit the assumptions again
we assume that the uh the wheel torque
is linearly proportional to the steering
torque so we assume that you know you
apply some steering torque and the wheel
torque is some factor of that and then
we forgot about it but turns out that's
also not true uh we assume that the uh
there are effects like backlash so when
you're turning left and when you're
turning and immediately you have to turn
right there is like a there is some
player in the steering column there's
like a backlash that you have to
overcome and then it's your car starts
turning right while driving we don't
really realize this because you know
humans are really good at driving but
when you're controlling the car through
instructions you realize you know there
are all these effects at play that you
have to account for
the other assumption was that we didn't
care much about speed we assume that
everything works the same at all speeds
uh you know like that's fine uh but
turns out this is also not true for some
platforms a different speeds your car
behaves very differently and this also
needs to be accounted for
so for example if you take the same plot
of the lateral acceleration that we
desire versus the steering command that
you input this is for the Chevrolet bolt
I mean this looks pretty non-linear to
me uh the if you remember in the RAV4 it
was pretty linear and in this it's not
um so you know we had to do something
about this because the same if you apply
the same algorithm that we used earlier
uh people have like not nice experiences
especially at the extremes where it's
like it gets pretty non-linear
so we implemented a non-linear algorithm
where we have a non-linear fit for the
relationship between this lateral
acceleration that you want to drive on
and the command that you give and then
this was out in 093 and you can see the
effect of uh this change so the
non-linear is is better than the linear
which is also correct
and a fun fact is you can see that there
is like a bit there is a difference in
the left turn and the right turn this is
like an idiosyncrasy of of GMS and all
these are super interesting things
because we can see this at scale and
it's very hard to see this if you have
one car but you can see that the errors
are slightly higher for left turns than
right turns it's because you're the in
in Chevrolets
the left turn is slightly different in
compared to right turns and I mean I
don't know why but it just is uh and
this also we need to account for uh so
uh this is some this was like a great
Improvement for the people using uh
people who have a Chevrolet bolt
so where do we go from this right uh
we've seen that you know over time we
keep improving the stuff uh we keep like
making sure that we move from platform
we've moved from Fleet averages to
platform averages and from platform
stuff to each individual cars so a big
effort for that was we uh released this
data set called comma steering control
and this data set is
the largest data set of its kind so what
it has is it has
the actual command that you give to the
car which is the steer command and all
the other metadata like the lateral
acceleration the road roll the velocity
uh a whole bunch of other stuff now this
is excellent because this is this data
is something that probably nobody else
has like we are in a unique position to
have so much data about so many
different platforms across different
driving conditions different uh like
weather conditions and all of that stuff
and different like usages like the cars
have different wear and tear so this is
like a fantastic data set
which with all this data so what you can
and this is like 12 500 hours of open
driving open pilot driving uh 10 plus
car models and 10 plus Brands and we
have plans to add more data to this we
have plans to add
non-open pilot driving so when we when I
spoke earlier about the vehicle mark
order that vehicle model is valid for
like small slip angles which I mean by
like you know like small steering on a
highway but if you want to do a rapid
180 degree turn the vehicle model
completely breaks down like you can't
use the same vehicle model for that uh
in open pilot we are not there yet to do
180 degree turns but we will be and at
that time we will have to dive deeper
into into the data and figure out you
know how we can improve our algorithms
to uh to cater to those manures uh so
this data set has all of this
information uh so some people on discard
have already started using this so they
have some obscure brand that not many
open pilot users use so now they have
like access to a whole lot of data that
they can like dive into and they can see
if they can improve the performance of
their own particular car which is
correct
uh so what what is the future for tuning
and controls right
so we want to use more neural techniques
to learn the complicated feed for
forward functions so you saw we started
with like a simple linear model and then
we went to linear model on device and
then we went to a non-linear but which
still like it's still we we sort of uh
reverse engineer the function and then
we learn it but we want to move to like
a totally learned uh function so what
this means is there'll be like
irrespective of what the input and
output is in your car we should be able
to learn the response of your car to the
instructions that we have that we give
to the car at all ranges of speeds there
are some cars that do automatic roll
compensation in the car and all of this
stuff we want to be able to learn all of
this stuff live in in your particular
car
uh the final goal is to move to like a
target audience of one so basically the
target audience of like you and like
everything is tuned to your car and it
drives perfectly like the output of the
model and the planner is perfectly
implemented on your car and uh you know
there is and then the final goal is me
not getting any more messages on
discards saying can you tune my car yeah
so uh that's that's it I just had a
couple of call outs so do check out this
data set do come on the uh Discord
Channel and we keep discussing a lot on
the Discord Channel
um so you know hopefully uh you can
improve your own car much better and
then we can Upstream it that would be
great and a call out to uh open pilot
user uh travel Sinker he's been uh like
at the bleeding edge of a lot of this
stuff I just wanted to call him out and
say that's like great work and we keep
watching it and uh we're very inspired
and I hope this also inspires more
people to check out what's happening
inside their car that is great
awesome
a lot of this stuff I just want to call
him out and say that's like great work
if you guys have any questions
all right we got lots of questions
in the front
so are all platforms using the torque D
or ID for the automatic tuning or that
still needs to be flushed out so
um all Toyotas all Hyundai's
so I think it's about 80 percent of our
Fleet uses it the Honda has turned uh
because that is like a there is a little
bit of problem with the Hondas I mean
they also work really well on on
traditional PID control uh so uh yeah I
mean most most cars use it and the plan
is to roll it out to all cars
great
hello so is longitudinal going to be
um in the foreseeable future for auto
tuning
yeah so that's a good question so the
thing is the lateral tuning uh was very
much a function of control
like it's it's very much defined by the
vehicle model and and the physics behind
it and a lot of the issues that we used
to have was not handling the physics
properly but the thing with longitudinal
tuning is that it's it's not much as
physics as much as there is a lot of lag
and we don't handle the lag compensation
properly in longitudinal and it's like a
bit tricky uh to go over that so
the problems that are with lateral
tuning is very different from the
problems with longitudinal tuning so I
mean yes to answer your question yes we
will have uh we will have all the
parameters learned live in the car but
it won't be part of talk D like that's
that's acceptable I mean it's like doing
something else there will be something
else like that which will learn all the
parameters required for longitudinal
gotcha thank you
great
so the problems that are with lateral
tuning is very difficult I think my
question is kind of similar to the last
question but
um how do you deal with like hysteresis
which is like uh basically actuator lag
like uh like for longitudinal you said
there's not much been done yet but for a
lot latitude like uh is it compensated
for in the motion planning or like
yeah so uh so what we call friction is
like is a manifestation of this
hysteresis effect which we already
handle in open pilot in dot T we already
compute what this uh the the hysteresis
component looks like and we already
handle this so if you if you see the
plots uh
I don't know I've cracked in
pull something up so we have uh so what
oh yeah if you see these plots so this
is from our uh from the uh
data set
yeah so if you see this so this is from
the data set that we released uh so the
effect there is all hysteresis uh I mean
you see the the width in the in the plot
right uh and this is already accounted
for in uh in part D uh and you know I
mean we have more effects like that
which are not exactly hysteresis but
they have this like sort of discrete
jump type of effects uh which is you
know more stuff for us to handle but uh
yeah I mean hysteresis is handled in
taught me right now
uh what is the uh optimal model of tire
for open pilot 0.9 according to the data
yeah that's that's a good question so
I guess to answer that the word there is
an optimal model of a tire and there is
a simple and useful model of the tire
which is what we follow uh if you ask
for the perfect model of the tire I mean
you can find many textbooks on this one
topic on like what is sorry I meant like
the make and model like oh I see
actually we'll be using Michelin or oh I
see I get you I got you uh
I'm not sure the thing is we don't uh
from logs can get the model of a tire so
uh I guess that's something that we
don't have access to uh but we certainly
understand what sort of uh like which
platforms have like uh what sort of
effects in following our instructions
and that's something that we can comment
on but uh
yeah we don't have access to the make
and model of the tire
all right I got a question up front
is it on the road map to
replace the current controls and and
tuning system with the completely
end-to-end machine Learning System
yeah there it is uh but I guess it's not
to replace but to build on uh which is
as George said as everybody's been
saying I think iterative Improvement is
something that is like a core tenet a
comma so uh we had something very
simplistic and then we moved to
something a little more complex and a
little more complicated and then you
know that's I guess the direction it'll
be going in uh we will have much much
smarter techniques that learn everything
that needs to be learned like while
you're driving and then uh yeah so it's
not it won't be like a replacement as
much as just building on what we already
have
all right thank you give it up for her
back